Art as they say, is subjective, what one person
considers a priceless masterpiece others might
see as nothing more than a giant black square…
But there’s one very specific kind of painting
that most everyone sees the same way- the
kind with the weird eyes that seem to follow
you around the room.
So what causes this optical illusion of sorts
and how do artists achieve this effect?
It turns out, for even a moderately skilled
artist, this “ubiquitous gaze” effect
isn’t a difficult thing to achieve.
In a nutshell, all you need is a little illusion
of depth, so the person depicted appearing
at least somewhat 3D despite being on a 2D
canvas, and to direct the gaze of the eyes
such that they would be looking at someone
standing right in front of the picture.
So what exactly is going on here in our brains
that then makes it seem like the eyes follow
you even if you move away from being front
and center?
As demonstrated in 2004 by a team of researchers
from Ohio State University, as you move to
the side, the “near” and “far” points
of the 2D image don’t really change.
These near and far points are defined as visible
points that, if the image was 3-dimensional,
would appear nearest and furthest away from
the viewer at a given angle.
Summarising their findings, co-author of the
paper James Todd had the following to say:
The idea is simple – no matter what angle
you look at a painting from, the painting
itself doesn’t change.
You’re looking at a flat surface….
The key is that the near points and far points
of the picture remained the same no matter
the angle the picture was viewed from.
When observing real surfaces in the natural
environment the visual information that specifies
near and far points varies when we change
viewing direction.
When we observe a picture on the wall, on
the other hand, the visual information that
defines near and far points is unaffected
by viewing direction.
Still, we interpret this perceptually as if
it were a real object…
Thus, because the perspective, shadows, and
light on the painting don’t change as you
move around, if the eyes in the painting would
be staring directly at the observer if said
individual is standing in front of the painting,
it creates something of a mild optical illusion
in your brain such that the eyes will continue
to seem to stare at you as you move to the
side.
In contrast to the eyes following you trick,
if the artist tweaks the painting a bit such
that the eyes are looking off somewhere else
instead of directly out at a potential observer,
no matter where you stand, the eyes will never
seem to be looking at you.
The technique first began popularly showing
up in art around the 14th century when the
artist and architect Fillipo Brunelleshi introduced
the art world to the idea of “linear perspective”,
linear perspective being painting with the
idea of everything in the picture converging
on a specific point on the horizon, creating
the illusion of depth.
This, combined with skilled use of light and
shadow, allowed artists to create masterfully
realistic paintings, including sometimes of
people that stare at you creepily no matter
where you stand, and totally aren’t Scooby
Doo villains stalking you with the intent
to murder you in your sleep.
Speaking of one of the most famous and valuable
paintings in history being literally just
a big black square on a white canvas, and
just as unimaginatively named Black Square,
in 1964, a new avant-garde artist was introduced
to the art scene in the Swedish city of Gōteborg.
The fresh new artist was Pierre Brassau and
his work received rave reviews from critics
and art fans alike.
One critic in particular, Rolf Anderberg,
was so overwhelmed by Pierre’s talent that
he wrote the following review about his work,
which appeared in print the morning after
the exhibition: “Brassau paints with powerful
strokes, but also with clear determination.
His brush strokes twist with furious fastidiousness.
Pierre is an artist who performs with the
delicacy of a ballet dancer.”
The reviews were almost universally glowing.
All but one, that is.
One critic’s commentary on the new artist
was short and to the point: “Only an ape
could have done this.”The opinion was unpopular,
despite that the pieces of art looked strikingly
similar to “art” you commonly see stuck
to refrigerators, produced by 2 year olds
the world over.
It turns out, though, that the “ape” review
more or less hit the nail on the head.
Pierre Brassau was actually none other than
a young West African chimpanzee named Peter
who lived in the Borås djurpark zoo in Sweden.
The mastermind behind the hoax was journalist
Åke “Dacke” Axelsson.
Axelsson worked for the Swedish tabloid Gotebors-Tidningen
and came up with the idea of featuring the
primate paintings in an exhibition in order
to put the critics to the test- could they
distinguish between the work of true, highly
skilled avant-garde modern artists when compared
to the work of a random chimpanzee?
It turns out the answer is mostly no.
Although it should be noted that we’re guessing
the chimp couldn’t have painted a perfect
black square.
So that’s something I guess.
And if you’re wondering, once the hoax was
revealed, the critic who had previously compared
Pierre Brassau with a ballet dancer, Rolf
Anderberg, doggedly stuck by his assessment
and stated that Pierre’s work “was still
the best painting in
the exhibition”.